like you when you were 17 like there's
something very glamorous about this
lifestyle for a lot of girls right
yeah
I mean it can be seen it's kind of like
the game getting into the game is kind
of like
you're in the middle of an ocean
and you're just like in the middle of
the ocean and there's like a
what are those things that like save you
like a wrath yeah or a life is a
lifesaver whatever you call it yeah like
one of those that's the game that
symbolizes the game and you're already
in the middle of the ocean so you're
already like down bad
and which which is your analogy for
poverty yeah
yeah go to
boat or the
Lifesaver yeah
and um
and then you find your way to land
but there's something a lot of the girls
find it glamorous
right
yeah I mean when you first get into it
you do and girls who some girls who like
aren't in the lifestyle it can be seen
as glamorous and I mean there's some
glamorous parts
but like the working part especially the
streets it's not glamorous like in any
way or any of your it's work are any of
your tricks or John's um
guys that you would consider like
dating or anything like that do you ever
find them like oh this guy's cute
I haven't met one yet
um but I could think of that comes to
mind so you're not gonna fall in love
with one of these guys no I don't think
so no no it's just it's not because like
I'm a sex worker and you're you're a
client you know so
can you even fall in love in the I mean
you're 19 years old you're you've been
doing this for a couple years you're
you're you're you're a vet now I mean
I've watched you work you're you're very
no I'm not even going to do the Vets
like that because they are their stripes
I'm still learning yeah but you're very
good you're I think you're a pro but
can you even fall in love
um because you're so deep into this
like I said in my interview I think my
last interview there's someone for
everybody I believe that yeah I think
people need to expand their
Minds in terms of what is a acceptable
lifestyle and what what a monogamous or
a polygamous relationship is or
right yeah because other people have
different views on
monogamy and polygamy yeah
so in New York they just uh
decriminalized prostitution
right which you know could happen in
California and well here
um I believe they can't um
I believe it's either they can't like
prosecute you for it or something like
that here in La like they can't
prosecute you they're not Prosecuting
prostitution cases right now
okay and stuff the cops will roll up and
down fig and not really yeah they know
what's going on obviously but they don't
they're not I mean um I haven't gotten
arrested since
May so I have no idea
but um yeah
so you're looking to move is that right
yeah I'm moving to Vegas I'm very
excited I'm really excited to leave La
I'm so sick of LA
I'm like at my wits in with LA yeah I
went to Vegas with you on on that that
little documentary we shot yeah I didn't
use that footage but but I saw you
working in Vegas and you seem to be very
happy there
I I was I see so much more potential for
what you do there
yeah people have people are there to
party and spend money
which is perfect you know for a hoe
because you just I like it because
you're just walking around the strip in
the casinos talking to guys making money
going back down to the strip you know
like it's funner it's safer which is
important yeah fig seems just a
in a while because
I've had some issues with The Pimps like
they won't leave you alone yeah
especially because like some of them
know who I am
there was one that had me when I was a
minor
I was like 17 and
um he only I was only with him for like
a day or two I think like maybe yeah
just a day
and um I left him
and um he saw me again and he recognized
me and he was like
chasing me like down the track I went to
another track and he was on that track
chasing me on like he was literally
chasing me until I caught a date
and after that I was like I'm not gonna
go because situations like that have
happened before but he was like a gang
banger and he was like
threatening to like kidnap me and stuff
so I was like yeah I'm cool that's where
things get scary yeah because
um Figueroa is like right next to Hoover
which is like gang bang the [__] out you
know yeah that's that's what's really
changed with pimps and that's what's
confusing people see a pimp and I'm
calling everyone a pimp but as you
explained in one of your earlier
interviews yeah you call them whole
Hustlers yeah like 90 of these men out
here who are claiming to be pimps are
not pimps like they've never been laced
they've never been seasoned none of that
ever they're just gang members who
figure out copy and paste
they figure out how to make money off
these girls
yeah ho high slim yeah because I think a
real pimp
yo think think Kenny red or Bishop Don
Magic want
know how to play the game and do it in a
way where the women are
yeah I'm happy and everyone's taken care
of yeah I mean your job should be to
make that girl better period yeah that's
the underlying theme of the whole thing
yeah that people get all upset with me
because like oh you're supporting these
pimps but I'm not supporting the the
ones we're talking about the gang number
of ho-hustlers who who use drugs and
violence and threats and all that kind
of stuff right to get the girls to do
what they want yeah
I'm talking about some of the other ones
that are more respected and uh
those girls aren't forced into anything
right it's all by choice yeah
and it's got to be difficult when you
pick up a guy who's like
obese you know heavy overweight yeah I
went on a date with the guy that was
like just like that he was just as you
described I went on a date like that
yesterday
and he was fat as [__] like extremely
fat and smelled and he smelled too
and it was a [__] too so it was even
worse because I had to be down there you
know
I had to be down there but I just kind
of just like
I just don't breathe I guess I kind of
just
don't breathe and
I usually can finish pretty fast so yeah
yeah it's got to be a tough thing to be
yeah I mean you kind of just like
I don't see
as me like
like giving somebody head like you know
I don't even put like an effort as I
would if it was with somebody that I
liked and I was like really sucking
their dick you know
it's like I'm just like going through
the motions you know it's kind of like
I'm a robot on my dates
yeah do you ever get like famous or
celebrity clients
I mean I did I actually did
um
last month like at the end of the month
I was on the track
and yeah I'm not I'm not gonna do that
but um I was on the track and it was
super slow so I went to go sit in my car
um because it was freezing and I wanted
to take a little break and I posted an
ad to like make the time go by a little
bit
and I got a text message for I'll call
so I was like do you have FaceTime or
Google Duo because that's what I require
like that's what I those are my it's my
vetting process
make sure you guys got a copy yeah and
so when I facetimed him he was like
somebody that I had used to listen to
when I was like 15 16. he kind of fell
off a little bit but he's still famous
musician yeah yeah and um he was like
yeah I want I want I want a date I want
to alcohol
and I was like okay I mean but it was
regular like I I got more money off of
like regular white guy tricks you know
the best ones
then this then this guy but I mean it
was a nice experience you know like
I had fun yeah
and then I seen him again the next day
because he wanted to see me again but um
yeah
is the sex ever enjoyable it sounds like
it is
um no no no
no but if it was somebody you care for
it would be a very different story yeah
I mean like when I have sex with like
like people that like I care about like
like people that I'm with then yeah like
there's passion but when I'm at work you
gotta you know you got it different
I don't know the word you know what I
mean differentiate yes you got to do
that when you're at work
because
um
you know you just got to it takes a
special kind of guy to accept
a woman who will do what you do yeah
most guys whatever most guys would be
like
you know you're a [__] and you ain't
[__] you know I dealt with that when I
was younger
yeah I'm too much of a square to deal
with that
yeah I mean
I mean
I guess it's acceptable like for Pimps
because they're in the same situation
that hoes are you know they're in the
streets too and they gotta come up too
so they come together yeah
you guys are a good fit
yeah pimps and hoes pimps and hose
you had a pimp early on in your I had a
few you know
um my first one
I'm so embarrassed like to even talk
about it because he was like he was
actually a white boy
I know you gave me that look you're like
royalty
yes he was white
um I was I had I was very very new I had
only caught like one date ever
and um I was walking this was in San
Diego I was walking
um
and um he was just he like pulled over
and we started talking I was like oh
yeah I'm like I want to start to like
start trapping and stuff and he was like
oh I could teach you how to do it
but meanwhile this guy is like a whole
Square he he was like a white guy that
was like black you know what I mean he
like
grew up in the hood and stuff so he was
white on the outside like on the inside
and he was a whole Hustler you know he
ain't know what the [__] he was doing
at all
and then I had one that was like kind of
like my boyfriend or whatever
um then I had another one they were just
like all ain't [__]
moral of the story yeah that's that
seems to be the mo for a lot of these
Street Hustlers is they approach a girl
as a boyfriend
and then very quickly it turns into a
well that they do that with girls that
don't know any better like you can't
just go up to like a real Hall and be
like oh yeah I'm gonna be your boyfriend
she's gonna be like [__] I'm not
looking for a boyfriend like I'll pass
but I was young and I didn't know and
like I was very against the idea of like
having like just a straight up pimp
because I was like why would I give my
money to you you know I didn't
understand
on why a [__] would do that so
is there any reason that a girl would
have a pimp a respectable pimp that
well
um nine times out of ten hoes are not um
we're not business oriented
you know and we're not
um
how do I say it good with money yeah
we're not good with money
in fact I think a lot of them are very
bad at with money yeah very bad because
you always think like I could go out and
make some more
like a [__] will make like a really
nice trap and spin that whole [__] and
be like oh yeah I'll go I'll go make the
same amount tomorrow but what if you
don't make anything tomorrow or what if
it's slow out there or what if you don't
make as much as you did yesterday
you know and I guess a pimp
they they help you with that money
managing and then they make you better
you know
the right ones make sure you're dressed
the way you should be right taken care
of your nails all that stuff teach you
how to be professional
and uh in Vegas you'll be working the
casinos in the strip yeah
um it's a little bit difficult for me
because I'm only 19. you have basically
really had to be 21. oh wow
um but I'm over 18 obviously so I can
still work it but I can't like sit at
the bars and [__] that's right and I
can't sit at the slots for too long or
they'll card me
and then they'll be like
you know you can't what about what about
uh strip clubs or brothels or stuff like
that
the brothels I'm really iffy about the
brothels because they take like 50 and
I'm like
they take 50 for no reason too like it's
not even like you guys are doing
anything for me you know other than
giving me a platform
but the strip clubs are always a go I
wanted to go to this one it's called
like
Little Darlings or something like that
yeah it's in Vegas yeah
and what about things like you certainly
fans as we saw in that last video and
yeah my only fan
um
okay
you know
you get out of it what you put into it
probably
yeah I haven't really been I honestly
I've been slipping a little bit but
that's because I've been planning on
moving to Vegas and Like kind of
transitioning my career because I I will
not be playing the streets in Vegas oh
you won't I will not be on the track
there's a track out there and I will not
be on it
at all you won't catch me
but the strip and the casinos yeah I'll
be on the strip in the casinos and in
the club yeah no I saw how you were able
to connect with guys that were just
walking down the street and all of a
sudden you're like
yeah within minutes they're like all of
a sudden they're you guys he's got his
arm around you and you guys are walking
down the strip and you're going into his
into his Casino he's like wow that was
quick that almost didn't happen and it
was just a stranger you just met
yeah very interesting
yeah
I guess everybody's ready for fun there
yeah everybody is pretty much ready for
fun the last time I was out there which
was like
like a week ago it was like a country
convention
so there was like a lot of like
country men out there and stuff cowboy
hats and a lot of cowboy hats I was like
what the [__] is going on there's like
so many cowboy hats out here
but you're a beautiful woman you it
doesn't matter with a race with you
because you'll get white guys Mexican
guys everything yeah I don't like you
yeah like the first day I was like I
don't think they're gonna like me but
then I started I noticed that they were
like talking to like some other black
girls that honestly weren't that good
looking
so I was like oh yeah if they're talking
to them I'm for sure I'm for sure Top
Notch but I still got some money so
it was all good
yeah I've seen you in many different
situations when business was
doing well and and not so well and your
your mood your attitude
your mood was really solid just very
consistent throughout yeah like you you
got through the tough parts and the
crappy weather and everything and you
you just persevered and stuck by it and
had a had a less lucrative night and
then I've seen you where you're making
lots of money
person either way
I mean
it's hard work
because
I'm a black woman and racism is real you
know like it is really real I have been
out there like next to a white girl
that's not even like pot belly
not even looking right and they will
choose her over me
over me like all of this
because they want her skin color you
know I mean I understand you know you
want what you want but it can be very
frustrating especially when the girl I
get it if she like is like really bomb
I'm like hell yeah but nine times out of
ten like the white girls on the street
they be like
mediocre as [__]
and yet they make solid money yeah like
it's very consistent for them and um
you know like a black hoe has to
has 10 times harder she has to jump
through hoops and
[__]
fire flames and all types of [__] and
then you can't date black guys yeah but
the white girls will date black guys
yeah cause
um they're like nicer to them they're
nice to them yeah yeah like I I get a
lot of black guys that want to date me
but I don't want to date them because
I'm scared that they'll like do
something to me because I've been raped
by a black guy before out there yeah but
I've talked to a lot of Mexicans and
black girls who are white girls who will
not have that same problem yeah I've
talked to one and they're like my
biggest clientele is black guys and I'm
like [__]
[__] it couldn't be me I mean you know I
guess people like what they don't
usually have
yeah there's some because I know when I
go around a whole bunch of white guys
they're like oh wow like you know she
looks good and sometimes they'll choose
me like majority of the time really
they'll choose me over the white girl
because she's white and they're white
and they're like
I get that all the time I could get that
at home
you know
so you have family still
uh they didn't go anywhere you know you
talk to them mm-hmm
did I tell you about how my mom came out
here and visited me my real mom
she came in like August but she came
with my baby sister and it was really
nice I haven't seen them and since I was
like 10 years old
so
yeah and she's like very supportive of
me and um everything that I do and I
love her for that what what do people
like
squares not understand because there's
there's a whole different culture for
African-American
people in these low-income these
poverty-string neighborhoods and they
they can't they think that what you're
doing is awful right but there's a
culture that kind of understands that
what you're doing is is surviving better
than most right like people in the hood
they see like pimps and hoes like it's
kind of like a love and hate
relationship
they're like we know that they're making
money but we're still mad because you
know it's a sex industry so it's it's
naturally gonna
um attract like hate because it involves
sex and women and money
so I heard somebody I heard somebody say
recently there's only two Commodities in
the hood drugs and sex
that's it yeah
yeah
but that's what I think a lot of squares
don't understand is is they'll look at
it
a pimp and a hole and just like that's
just awful and you know that that's the
most evil terrible thing ever
but given the options that maybe you you
see in front of you right this is a
pretty good option for you I mean not
only that it's like it matters about
where you're going like yeah I sell my
body but
I mean I'm moving into a nice apartment
like a nice resort style apartment in
Vegas I'm going to be trying to like
get myself
out of the streets first and then out of
the game eventually and so and where
would you like to go in in five ten
years
um I want to go to school I had to
finish high school because I never
graduated I dropped out and
um like 10th grade
and so I had to finish that and then I
wanted to go to school for forensics oh
wow yeah I love science good for you
yeah there's a lot that people don't
understand about
different these cultures and the culture
you come from right yeah South Central
LA is just it's a different world than
how most white people grew up yeah I
mean I honestly we don't understand it I
can relate to how white people grow up
because I kind of grew up in the same
way I did not like
I didn't grow up in like a poverty
struck area
I just migrated over here because I was
emotionally abused at home and I decided
not to deal with that [__]
and I kind of just got LED over here
through like boyfriends and [__] it was
their sexual abuse in your childhood
um when I was like two I like was in
foster care and
um the foster mom had a son
and he was like addicted to pornography
and he would like take me down to the
garage and like touch on me and like
make me watch porn with him and that
made me very hypersexual as a child
yeah and that's another huge problem
with this hole Yeah
yeah that that whole culture is just it
happens every household of us something
like that yeah it went on until like I
left her um until I left her house
but it was sad because I actually I
didn't mind it which was the sad part
yeah do you have friends that do this
I don't have any friends I mean I have
like a couple of HPS but I haven't
talked to them in a really long time
yeah I have a couple of whole partners
but I don't really talk to them like
that because
um you know I like to keep it
professional you know I don't really
like to get into because she may have
folks and I don't want to get close to
her and her folks it's like she getting
close to you she must want to come home
and be with me I don't want that so I
kind of if I see you hey how you doing
and I go about my business
so you you avoid
situations where you might get
approached yeah I avoid I don't watch
your pimp thinking that I like you or
him or none of that
so so your basic overview opinion of a
of a real pimp not not a street
Hustler
is that they're they're kind of an okay
thing to have
I mean they're a great thing to have I
mean that's that's a hose man
you know that's her man it helps you
manage your money helps keep you
together helps keep you
on track yeah but you you don't even
really like think about that
like
when you're with them
it's really just your man like they
handle all of that [__] mm-hmm
yeah see that that's the part that white
folk just cannot wrap their heads I know
they're like she should be doing it for
herself or you shouldn't be doing it
period yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I
get that I get that you know you can't
put on a nurse's uniform and go work as
as a nurse tomorrow so yeah I can't
there there had to be steps to be taken
towards you yes and because of the way
you grew up you didn't have those
the steps right in front of you to take
right but maybe you can get there by
doing this and saving your money and
and building some kind of nest egg that
you can
jump to another career
right I mean
you use the money that you make in this
game to invest in something that will
get you out the game and you are saving
money right because if you just keep
making money and spending money and
making money and spending money you're
just gonna stay in the game you have to
invest in something like you have to or
you're just gonna be here I do not want
to be a hoe and I'm 30 years old let
alone 25 like I'm dead ass serious
I don't want that for myself
yeah you're very different than most of
the girls yeah I mean it's already been
I've already been
like
I just
I don't feel a need for it to go like
over five you know
what have you learned from your three
years of doing this
I've learned a lot I learned a lot where
do you want me to start you're a very
intelligent girl so I would think your
thoughts on
the kind of things you've learned about
Men about
yeah about security about life about
your making your dreams come true about
all these things there's probably
something that's working I guess the
most important thing that I've learned
is like to like embody
like
you know just like being feminine
you know because I could like walk
anywhere and it's like I still get like
attention like I I have whole appeal you
know I have trick appeal
yeah you sure do and um
and um I guess that is something that
I'll always know how to use to my
advantage because I work streets that
aren't even tracked sometimes and I do
well there you get hit on mm-hmm they'd
be like you know what's going on
and you'll turn the data at a shopping
mall or whatever yeah gas stations
there's tricks at every single gas
station really yes when you go to pump
gas there is one there I promise you
he's looking at you you just gotta
strike up a conversation
and negotiate and then you guys will go
off to a car date or a hotel motel
hard date like if I'm out like
just in like a random area I'll just be
like walking around going up to people
at the pumps you know I might ask them
like to go buy me something out the
store or something just to see if
they're like you know
generous first and then I'll lead up to
that
and you got yourself off of crystal meth
which was yes I did and the other day
yesterday I actually
um I was down and um this guy pulled up
and he was like literally like smoking
out of his poopy like in that moment he
was like do you want to smoke a bowl and
I was like No And I said it with so much
confidence and I had like no I had not a
single lick of Temptation and I was so
proud of myself
you should be very proud of myself
the weight is taking a very long time to
come back
but um I'm waiting on it I'm waiting on
it you look just fine thank you what
advice would you give to a square woman
a girl that's not playing this in the
game about
attractiveness and
relationship relationships with men
yeah I feel like if you're a square if
you're a woman in general you could
still make a bag from a man like you do
not have to be like a full-blown hoe
because I did it when I was a square you
know
um I didn't have the game and the tools
that I have now so I didn't get as much
but
um
just always know that like just to
embody you being a female like you
literally are the most sought out
I guess not an object but you know what
I mean in the world I mean when you're
dressing you're dressed beautifully
right now
from head to toe and are you dressing in
terms of what a man might respond to or
what you feel comfortable with what you
feel good about
um or both when I a little bit of both a
little bit of both
the club yeah I think it's really cute
um
and I mean guys seem to like it too so
yes that much they're not like yeah
well I think I think you're remarkable
your personality your your strength your
determination to
rise above right rise out of the
situation you're in is remarkable and
you deserve everything good that's going
to happen to you
thank you Mark royalty thank you so much
good luck in Vegas
thanks hope great things happen for you
there thank you thank you very much okay